[Music]
this morning on the dish australian-born
chef Jeanine booth born into a family of
restaurant owners she was inspired by
the food of Australia's many cultures
and decided to become a chef after
starting her career in Miami she took
her love of Southern cuisine north to
New York in 2014 she and partner Jeff
McInnis opened Rutten Bone celebrating
southern fare and country comforts they
followed up with a second branch in
Miami Beach and last year added stilts
ville fish bar offering local locally
sourced seafood in Miami's sunset Harbor
neighborhood chef Jeanine booth good
morning welcome to the dish why are you
thank you so much for having me thanks
for coming we are overwhelmed by the
size of this chicken look of that cake
tell us what else is in store for us
here so we have a little buffet here
today kind of a journey through all of
the restaurants that I've opened over
the last few years so we have this
coconut shrimp which is a dish that we
have on our restaurant in Miami called
the silk film it's a coconut shrimp
these are our deviled eggs from Rudin
born here in New York City and we also
have a location in Miami and this is the
fried chicken from written one it's a
signature dish without buttermilk
biscuits and there's a little lemon
powder on the fried chicken it gives the
chicken I'm a really nice ding and then
just some simple root vegetables and of
course we've got to finish with dessert
right so this is a lemon cake decadent
with some whipped cream and strawberries
very simple stuff but really really nice
elevated versions of all the classic
dishes that you're really really
accustomed to please tell me what this
so I love gin I love champagne I love
strawberries and it's summer right now
so rhubarb is insane so we made a little
spritz that for you guys the next
refresh is delicious so you grew up in
the restaurant industry as I said but
when did you know that food was your
passion and was what you were going to
do so I was probably around 12 years old
I started taking cooking class lessons
at school and my parents loved to cook
but really my dad actually owned a
couple of restaurants when I was growing
up and so I kind of grew up in the
industry but he stay away from it he did
yeah he was
look you can you can go into the
industry if you want but you know you're
gonna be working every weekend and a lot
of holidays and and you know you're not
gonna get to spend a lot of time with
your family okay and I tried to you know
go into different fields and I went to
tried nursing I tried teaching I know
and I and my parents like what is going
on she's going in all these different
directions and eventually I ended up
back in culinary school and that was
when I really just found my place and
and it was just it just really made
sense for me but you had a stint of
traveling the world as well I think
there's nothing better than backpacking
through countries so yeah I left high
school and I saved up all of my money I
I worked in like an administration job
and I just saved up all my money and I
was really focused I wanted to go
traveling and really save the world and
and discover more about different
coaches and cuisines and so it was a
really great time I traveled for about
nine months and all through Europe and
Thailand and Indonesia and it was just a
really eye-opening experience of me and
it was really really special and then
when I got home to Perth my parents are
like okay it's time for me it was over a
meal in Miami that you met Jeff McInnis
right that's really what started this
partnership yes so I met Jeff at a
restaurant called GG's he was working at
he was the chef and I ate this meatloaf
dish and it was absolutely incredible
hmm and I had just moved from Australia
and I never really had meatloaf before
and Mike is if this is what meatloaf is
then like I know exactly what everyone's
been talking about this whole time but
it was like great short rib and it was
it was not your regular meatloaf and so
I asked to meet the chef because I just
wanted to figure out how to make the
dish and he was too busy and I actually
went back on the same night and ate the
same dish a second time that night
because it was just so good and it was
all I could think about and eventually
he was like oh is that go back again I
better go made pressure
okay so he was like well if you want to
learn how to make this meatloaf I'm not
just gonna give out my recipe you have
to come work for me so I was in culinary
school at the time so it was a perfect
kind of introduction to the the industry
so as I hand you this dish to sign yeah
if you could have this meal with anyone
past or present who would it be
so obviously I'm from Australia and all
my family is still out there and I get
back about once a year
but I would definitely want to share it
with them with my parents and my sisters
and my nephews and my daughter Sonny and
Brice and and Jeff of course awesome
well we thank you chef Jeanine booth we
so are excited about digging in aren't
we and for more of chef Boots's booth
and the dish head to our website at CBS
this morning calm